>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Foreign language ]
>> Lucia Wolf: Welcome,
we are very pleased
to have you here this evening
for this wonderful event.
The first week of Italian Cuisine
in the World, so very exciting.
And we are very pleased to have
two wonderful food historians
and chefs here.
Before I introduce them, I
would like to talk a little bit
about the Italian collections
of the Library of Congress.
We have 450,000 items across
divisions in our collections.
So it's quite a huge collection.
And for Italian cooking,
I counted 1,900 books,
for Italian cooking alone.
So we have a small display outside.
It shows a range of books
in our general collections.
But one of these days, we
will also have a nice exhibit
of our rare books and
special collections.
So I am Lucia Wolf.
I work at the European division.
I am responsible for the
Italian collections, of course.
And also of Malta, Vaticano, San
Marino, and Italian-Switzerland.
So those are my fields.
If you ever have some
questions, please come and see me.
Anybody can request and use our
books at the Library of Congress.
So we're happy to be here
and to help you all out.
But let's introduce our speakers.
So, Domenica Marchetti.
Domenica Marchetti grew
up in an Italian family.
Her mother is from
Chieti, in Abruzzo.
And of her family, Domenica
says, "At the dinner table,
we spent more time talking about
what we should eat the next day,
rather than politics and
the news of the day."
I can relate, being Italian.
But I have to say that I had some
of my best political discussions
with my father, at the dinner table.
Domenica refers to
another experience.
She says that her mother had her
sister and her shaping gnocchi
and ravioli by the time they could
see over the kitchen counter.
This too, is a very common
experience in Italian families.
Domenica graduated from
Columbia's School of Journalism.
Started her career as
a newspaper reporter.
And wrote about a lot of topics,
until she realized that writing
about Italian food was her calling.
Her recipes and articles on
Italian cuisine are featured
in many national publications.
Including Cooking Light,
Fine Cooking, Food and Wine,
The Chicago Tribune,
The Washington Post,
and the list goes on and on.
So she is the author of seven books,
which we do have, I am happy to say,
in our collections at the Library.
Preserving Italy:
Canning, Curing, Infusing,
and Bottling Italian Flavors
and Traditions is
her latest book, 2016.
Thank you, Connie, for
bringing her personal copy over,
because I had trouble
getting, requesting the book.
Ciao Biscotti.
The Glorious Vegetables of Italy.
The Glorious Pasta of Italy.
Williams-Sonoma, Rustic
Italian: Simple,
Authentic Recipes
for Everyday Cooking.
Big Night In: More Than 100
Wonderful Recipes for Feeding Family
and Friends Italian-Style.
And The Glorious Soups
and Stews of Italy.
To learn more about Domenica,
you can refer to her
blog, domenicacooks.com.
Now for Amy Riolo.
Amy Riolo is no stranger
to the Library of Congress.
She has been here on various
occasions for various lectures.
But, for those who do not know
about Amy, she is an award-winning,
best-selling author, chef,
television personality.
And in this case, too,
it goes on and on.
I wouldn't have enough
time to talk about all
of Amy's achievements here.
Amy comes from an American
family, originally from Calabria.
Calabria is Southern Italy, the
tip of the boot, I like saying.
So you guys have an
idea where that is.
She graduated from
Cornell University.
And set out to become one of the
most respected culinary diplomats
and advocates of the
Mediterranean diet.
Her most recent book, The Italian
Diabetes Cookbook was released
on January, 2016, and is in our
display, among other books by Amy.
Among them, The Ultimate
Mediterranean Diet Cookbook.
The Mediterranean
Diabetes Cookbook.
Nile Style: Egyptian
Cuisine and Culture.
Arabian Delights: Recipes &
Princely Entertaining Ideas
from the Arabian Peninsula.
She makes -- Amy makes
frequent appearances
on many television
and radio programs.
Including Fox TV, ABC,
CBS, NBC, Nile TV,
and Abu Dhabi Television.
She was in Morocco,
just before coming here.
>> Wow!
>> Lucia Wolf: Yes.
Her delicious recipes
grace the pages
of many newspapers and magazines.
Including, USA Today, Cooking
Light, The Washington Post,
CNN.com, and The
Wall Street Journal.
Again, the list goes on and on.
If you would like to learn
more about Amy, her blog,
amyriolo.com is full of interesting
information and wonderful recipes.
Such as her mouthwatering
mussels and tomato saffron broth.
That made me want to get
up and make it last Sunday.
So it is impossible for
me to say more about Amy's
and Domenica's achievements
in such a brief introduction.
And I will let the speakers
do it for themselves.
And now to Domenica
Marchetti and Amy Riolo.
Enjoy.
[ Applause ]
>> Domenica Marchetti:
Hi, thank you.
Thank you, Lucia, for that
that lovely introduction.
Hi everyone, thanks so much
for joining us this evening.
I was contacted by Renato,
from the Italian Embassy,
to speak about Italian food.
Which is a subject near
and dear to my heart.
I have seven books
on Italian cooking.
So it's something I think
about pretty much 24-7.
And I was thinking about
the theme of this week,
Italian Food in the World.
Italian Cuisine in the World.
And so I'm just going to give
you a little bit of an overview
on my thoughts on that subject.
And then Amy has prepared a
wonderful PowerPoint presentation
for us.
I was thinking about my most
recent book, Preserving Italy.
And the double entendre is
definitely on purpose there,
in the title of the book.
On the surface, it's a book
about Italian preserving
traditions in the kitchen.
[ Foreign Language ]
So foods preserved in oil,
foods preserved in vinegar.
Marmalade's, jams, fruit
pastes, syrups, liquors.
Everything from those things
to fresh cheeses and salami.
Because if you think of the Italian
table, so many foods that come
to the Italian table, are
foods that have been preserved.
Preserving the bounty
of Italian ingredients.
And even if you're not Italian,
chances are, you are familiar
with most of these foods.
If you go to just about
any supermarket these days,
you will find jars of Giardiniera.
Or roasted peppers, or, pancetta and
guanciale in the deli department.
When I was growing up,
these things were not quite
as common as they are now.
But they are pretty much everywhere.
But beyond that, the book is also
about preserving these traditions.
These ways, these food ways,
these ways of these techniques.
And, you know, the world is
ever-changing, Italy is changing.
And so it was important to me, as
somebody who loves Italian cuisine,
to try to maybe bottle
some of these recipes
and old traditions in this book.
I have to say, though, ultimately,
it's a kind of a futile endeavor,
because food is always evolving.
Cuisine is always evolving.
And when you think about
Italian food in the world,
you know, you really do see that.
And the more I thought
about this subject,
the more I realized
that Italian food.
Or the food of the
peninsula, I should say,
before there was an Italy.
There's always been the food of the
Italian peninsula out in the world.
Whether it was through the spread of
the Roman Empire, to food traditions
that traveled to France
with Caterina de' Medici.
And also the foods that Thomas
Jefferson introduced to the U.S.
after traveling to Italy.
Including pasta, or
macaroni, gelato, ice cream,
and even rice he brought back.
Nowadays, we have chefs who,
you know, even here in D.C.,
who travel to Italy in
search of authentic recipes.
And they bring them back to their
own restaurants here in the U.S.,
and elsewhere in the world.
So that's a little
bit of an overview
about Italian food in the world.
But, as I was thinking of
the subject, I thought,
you know, it's not just that.
If you turn it around, you
have the world in Italian food,
or the world of Italian food.
And so that's kind of looking at
things in a different perspective.
There's always been a
cross-cultural influences
in what we broadly refer
to as Italian cuisine.
Whether this is a result
of war, invasion, religion,
migration, travel, and so on.
So, you know, you think
about Sicilian food.
And the influence of
Arab and African culture
and ingredients on
the food of Sicily.
And you think of the New World,
and the ingredients brought
from the New World back to Italy.
Potatoes, peppers, tomatoes.
I mean, to me, the aroma of roasted
peppers is the aroma of Italy.
But, of course, and you know,
in the history of the world,
peppers are a pretty recent
introduction into the cuisine
of the Italian Peninsula.
So, and in the 18th
and 19th century,
we had the so-called
British invasion of Italy.
Where a lot of British people you
know, the poets, the romantics,
moved to Italy, wrote about
the Italian landscape.
And they brought with them,
things like roast beef.
So even today, if you go to Tuscany,
you can find in the
trattorias, roast beef.
Which is, basically, you know, the
Tuscan variation of a British food.
So all of these things were kind
of rolling around in my head.
And it's a very complex
subject, as we know.
And, as I was thinking of it,
I thought of my friend Amy,
who is a food historian
and a cookbook author.
And just a really a
font of knowledge
on the history of Italian cuisine.
So I asked her to come with me
and delve into this subject today.
And she's prepared a wonderful
PowerPoint, which we're going
to kind of get into slide by slide.
And talk a little bit about the
evolution of Italian cuisine,
from the beginning to now.
And also kind of look
back at the evolution of,
or how world cuisine has
influenced the food of Italy.
So without further ado, I'd like to,
for us to get started
on the PowerPoint.
Please, we will be taking
questions afterward.
We'd love to hear your perspective.
We'd love to hear your comments.
Your own experiences.
You know, whether Italian or not,
I think pretty much everybody
in the world loves Italian food.
So, and everybody has an opinion
about it -- an opinion about it too.
So, okay, Amy, come on over.
>> Amy Riolo: Thank
you so much, Domenica.
Thank you all so much for
coming this afternoon.
What a huge pleasure and honor
it is to have all of you here.
As I look around, I see
a lot of familiar faces.
Some of you from prominent
Italian organizations, the Embassy.
Others, really important
Italian restaurants.
And other restaurant's
chefs here with us today.
And people from the Library of
Congress, who I've known for years.
So it's great to be
in such good company.
And I'm really grateful to Domenica.
And we've worked together for
years now, on different topics.
And doing different discussions
for the National Italian American
Foundation, for [foreign word].
For different things
that we work with.
And, if there's no other take
away than anything else today.
What I would like for everybody
to remember, is that there is room
for more than one Italian.
Because, you know, as an Italian,
or as an Italian American,
in any field, there is one box.
And if it's filled, if Domenica
is doing it, I'm not doing it.
If I'm doing it, she's not doing it.
Or vice versa.
So there's so much to say, as
you're going to see, you know,
on the topic of Italian cuisine.
That there could be 50
of us, 5,000 of us here,
and we would all have
something unique to say.
And I thought of that last night,
because we were talking
a little bit about today.
And I said, you know, we're talking
about a very unique, niche topic.
She has a complete
different view than me.
We're Italian American, we're women,
we're authors, but very different.
So that's the first thing I'd
like to say, before we start.
And the other thing is,
this is a very large topic.
I'll start teaching a series in
January, every Tuesday evening.
I'll teach an Italian culinary
appreciation certification series
at L'Academie de Cuisine,
in Bethesda.
But it will take even more
than that one semester to talk.
So please don't hate us if we
left out your favorite topic.
We can -- we'll address it in a Q&A.
So here are some things, if
anybody's on the Internet,
and would like to use some hashtags.
November 16th, officially,
is the start off
of the Italian Cuisine
in the World week.
So feel free to use that hashtag,
since this is the first one.
We've been trying to
get some traction
and make this a really
popular event.
These are all of our handles.
And then, a couple of fun facts.
Italian food is now the
number one in the cuisine
in U.S. and in the world.
More pizza is eaten per capita,
in the U.S., than in Italy.
And pizzas served to Americans
on July 4th, in troops overseas.
Italian food, of course, is
also the most misrepresented
and misunderstood in the world.
So we're going to talk
a little bit about that.
Made in Italy labeling,
the geographic indicators
are very, very important.
For that reason, we'll
talk about those.
And only a third of the
Italian foods that are eaten
in the world actually
come from Italy.
So we're going to discuss
the history of Italian food.
Some cultural events that
influenced the cuisine.
We'll also talk about
Italian cuisine today,
and its influence in the world.
So I'm going to start
back with the 8th century,
before the Common Era,
[foreign word].
So this is my ancestral
homeland of Calabria,
specifically the town of Crotone.
And in Calabria and in Lucania,
the neighboring Lucania,
they had something called lagane.
Which were the original pasta.
So many, many centuries before
the Etruscans had pasta,
and people were starting
their theories
about Marco Polo and
things like that.
We had lagane in some of the first
indigenous settlements in Italy.
That's the Temple of
Hera that you see,
and this is Pythagoras, down below.
Because they both had places
Crotone, believe it or not.
All of southern Italy, at this
time, was very important for Greece.
It was called the [foreign word].
And so a lot of famous foods came
from Greece, and went back to Greece
at that very, very early age.
In addition to what was
already found there.
And these pasta, this type
of past that's called lagane,
you can still find around today.
As Domenica mentioned, people are
trying to preserve some recipes.
And there are movements taking
place to preserve these recipes.
Lagane comes from the
Greek word lagana,
which was a bread eaten
on Clean Monday.
And so this idea of paste, or
dough, came over into Calabria,
and we started using that.
Then if we go into Rome, and we
look at places like Hadrian's Villa,
and what the emperors were doing.
We get a very good
glimpse into, you know,
quote Italian food culture,
very, very early on.
Because the Romans were
great purveyors of food.
And they really wanted
the best of everything.
So they would send fleets out
into North Africa and into China,
bringing back the best
spices from China.
They wanted the best shrimp,
from just the right time,
from the catch off
the shore of Libya.
They had people tracking these
things so that they knew.
They were great, great
purveyors of food, from early on.
And here on the left,
we see Hadrian's Villa.
And then, on the right, we can see
the Temple of Karnak, in Egypt.
So there was a lot of synergy
back then between ancient Egypt,
ancient Greece, and ancient Rome.
Here are some, an example
from 180 of the Common Era.
We can see what the trade
routes looked like then.
So, you know, for people
who thinking,
we don't have transport,
people were landlocked.
They didn't have the
globalization that we have today.
This is how much influx
they had going and coming.
Already, at that, time
the food was a fusion.
And then we talk about
some different things,
and really the development
of early Italian cooking.
We can talk about Apicius.
So Apicius was a Roman philosopher.
He wrote the first cookbook that
we know about, in the west called,
De re Culinaria, or On Cooking.
And this cookbook is
still around today.
You can see are different
types of it.
It's also been translated.
And Apicius was a poor philosopher.
He loved food.
He was a great, like, [foreign
word], as we say in Italian.
But he couldn't afford
what his pallet.
He had the pallet of an emperor,
but the budget of a philosopher.
So he actually committed suicide,
because he couldn't afford
to eat the way he wanted.
So he is believed to be the
father of all gourmands and chefs.
We all admire him and
revere him for this reason.
But, in Apicius' cookbook, he
wrote about a lot of things
from a lot of different places.
And one of the things he
wrote about was Numidia,
and this place called
Numidia Quadrata.
If any of you remember
taking the metro in Rome,
you might know there's a stop on
the Metro, called Numidia Quadrata.
And it refers to this place,
which you see over on the right.
It's the square area, from
Rome south, into North Africa,
which was Roman territory.
So this was the breadbasket
for the Romans.
And with the wheat and different
ingredients that they got there,
those were currency, an antiquity.
So they could trade and they could
fund the entire Roman Empire,
all the way up to Great Britain,
just from what came out
of Numidia Quadrata.
So this was like the
administrative capital.
And when I was in Morocco, I
just came back Saturday night.
One of the things -- places -- I
took my guests, was to Volubilis,
which was one of the
Roman outposts in Morocco.
Beautiful, you can see the olive
oil presses, and just, you know,
the amazing infrastructure
that the Romans had.
And how important food was
back then, and lifestyle.
And then if we go forward, we can
go all the way to the 9th century.
And talk about some of the
influences that were taking place
in Sicily, and in different places.
But what I'd like to
mention also before that is,
there were many different regions,
and Empires, and places that,
indigenous settlements, in Italy.
Long before we had some
of these invading forces,
or new forces coming in.
We look at the Romans a lot, because
they were such an impressive Empire.
They have so many things that
you can trace back and look
at them, and know what is Roman.
And a lot of Italian Americans
really identified, and Italians,
identify themselves
with what is Rome.
Because Rome is so
important in the world.
But there were a lot of other
indigenous tribes that were on too.
Like the Etruscans in Tuscany.
Like, in Calabria, we had the
Italian, the [foreign word].
In Puglia, they had the Apulians.
So these people were already there,
already had their own culture.
And then if the Romans
were to come into an area,
they were another culture coming in.
It's not like everybody was Roman.
So that's an important
distinction to make.
And then if we look into the
9th century, two very important,
prominent groups came in from
North Africa, into Sicily.
One was the Aghlabids,
and they came in in 827.
The reason Sicily was so important,
is because it's the largest
island in the Mediterranean.
It was the center of trade.
So any caliphate wanted to
claim Sicily before it claimed
other areas.
And sometimes Sicily was
actually known as a caliphate.
So the Aghlabids came from what was
now known as modern-day Tunisia.
And they named Marsala,
which means Mars Allah,
or the marsh of Allah,
the Port of Allah.
They named it that.
And they also brought in a lot of
different ingredients with them.
A lot of lemons.
A lot of mulberries.
A lot of different citrus,
and couscous, and things like.
And they would plant the fruits
on the base of Mount Etna.
So all of that rich soil
really enriched a lot
of the products, and
made them superior.
If you go to North Africa
today, the little lemons
and oranges are like this big.
They're very delicious, they're
sweet, their own variety.
But they took a whole new
thing once they got enriched
from the volcanic soil.
So when, sometimes if you're
overseas, if you're in a store
and you see something, you know,
grown in the volcanic
ash of Etna or Sicily.
And you're like, that's
just a marketing ploy.
If It really was, it really,
it's not a marketing ploy.
It's unique, it's different.
Those years and years of
ash really make a superior
and a different product.
So that's interesting to know about
and interesting to talk about.
And then in 917, the Fatimids came.
And the Fatimids were
really, really important.
They were also, they were a Shiite
group, also from North Africa,
from what is now Tunisia.
But they were important, because
they first claimed Sicily,
Palermo, as their capital.
And then 50 years later,
they claimed Cairo.
So that's how important
Sicily was to them.
And there was a lot of synergy back
and forth, between Cairo and Sicily,
because of that in those days.
Also the Fatimids were
really big into kind
of cross-cultural celebrations.
So they would have
religious festivals.
They didn't care if people were
Jewish, or Christian, or Muslim.
They would have these festivals
and then they would make what
we now know as [foreign word],
or the sesame candy
and things like that.
And those would be the sweats
of the different festivals.
And they would encourage
everybody to eat them.
So nowadays, if you go to the --
>> Domenica Marchetti:
Well, he was going to --
you still see these sweats
at community festivals.
>> Amy Riolo: That's right.
>> Domenica Marchetti: The sugared
almonds, the [foreign word].
>> Amy Riolo: And if you go to, you
know, the feast of Saint Rosalia,
in Sicily, you'll see them.
Or if you go to the
Prophet Mohamed's birthday,
in Cairo, you'll see them.
Nobody realizes that people
are, across the pond are,
especially the more
provincial people,
don't realize that people are
eating them for different reasons.
But they're one of the very
early examples that we have,
of a food that goes across cultures.
And they became a very,
very powerful group.
And then, the next big time period
that we have, if we leap forward,
that we can talk about,
is the Renaissance.
And, as Domenica mentioned
earlier, Catarina de' Medici,
when she married Henry
II and moved to Paris,
she brought with her
all of her cooks.
So this huge brigade of pastry
chefs and regular chefs.
So what we now know, what became the
Grande Cuisine Movement, in Paris,
was actually influenced
by Florentine cuisine.
We couldn't call it
Italian at that time,
because we didn't think
of things as Italy.
It was pre that.
But it was Florentine.
And many of the French
chefs will, you know,
have studied that, and history.
So things like onion soup.
Things like, that we
call French onion soup,
crepes, Duck a l' orange.
These types things, the
amaretti cookies fused
into what we now know
as the macaron.
So there were many, many
elevated dining styles,
but also specific recipes that the
Medicis brought with them to Paris.
And then another important thing to
think about, if we're kind of trying
to get our minds wrapped
around what was taking place,
in the time of the Renaissance.
And, you know, so much wealth,
and so much learning,
and so much knowledge.
But still so much trade with
the East, that at that time,
an Oriental carpet was
worth more than the David.
Can you imagine?
And kind of, if you took
it to nowadays standards,
so you have to think about.
So if an oriental carpet
was worth more,
imagine how much spices were worth.
Imagine how much other
things that were [inaudible].
Blown glass, for example,
from Syria, was really close
to priceless at that time.
They had so many knockoffs.
And they used to write in fake
Arabic to try to sell them.
And I say this as it
applies to food,
because the food was also
influenced from those styles.
So we see a lot of spices,
starting to come in.
And people like, you know,
beyond the Medicis wanting
to show off at the banquet, even.
And at the Papal banquets
and the things
that were going on at the Vatican.
When they wanted to have something
luxurious, they added spice,
because it showed that
they had money.
Spice was a form of currency.
Spice was used as a
traditional medicinal.
Spice was used as a show of
wealth, as a mood enhancer,
all kinds of different things.
But at that time, Venice and
Istanbul, over top right,
and Cairo, were all sister cities.
And they were all involved
in the spice trade.
All of those cities, the things
would go around and around.
The merchants would just keep
bringing them back and forth.
Were all built pretty much on spice.
All of the beauty that, you
know, all of the grandeur,
all of the wonderful wealth that
is hard to even comprehend today.
Maybe we would think
about it with petroleum.
They were all built on spice.
One of the unique things that
happened, though, to Venice,
in terms, that didn't
happen to other cities.
Was when the Dutch later on found
a new trade route to the east,
they didn't need these
cities anymore.
So they were all going
to go bankrupt.
And they knew.
There was like a little
bit of advanced warning,
that they all knew they
were going to suffer
from these new trade routes.
And not needing the Mediterranean
and the Middle East anymore.
But what the Venetians
did was really cool was,
they took the residual
money that they had.
And instead of holding onto it
because they were going
to go bankrupt.
They actually spent
it on the frescoes
that you can see on the canal.
So all of this additional
beauty came out of a time
that most people would have been
really worried about failure.
And then, of course, Venice became
a popular tourist destination,
because it was so beautiful.
So it helped us to kind of, you
know, live through that moment.
And it's a really good
example of food and culture,
and kind of cities in the world.
Then again, we have to
talk about Da Vinci.
Because -- and I would've
loved to talk about,
you know, 500 different figures.
But, to just choose
one, this is important.
Because in the 15th century,
and the 16th century.
When you're looking at all
of these titles that had --
Lucia was making fun of me.
Because I have three slashes
in my professional title.
But look at his, and
they were all like that.
And it wasn't the first
time, you know.
There were many, many people
during the Renaissance.
Hence, the term Renaissance man.
In two centuries prior, in Baghdad,
many of those scholars
were also like that.
They had all these same things.
And so, as we were taking many ideas
from the east, so was this idea
of being able to do many things.
Of expanding the mind.
Of no limits.
Of not having to be so focused.
Of science, and knowledge, and
learning, and math, and food.
And all being intertwined.
We also see more formal
ways of writing
about food and appreciating food.
Because, for a while, you know,
that food was just something
that you would talk
about for the wealthy.
For the upper-class.
For the people in the palaces.
And now we start to see it really
being looked at as a science.
And it's thanks to people
like this, in addition to all
of the many wonderful advancements
that they made in society.
And then, as Domenica
mentioned, Columbus.
And, of course, coming
to the New World.
And regardless of the individual
that came, or, you know,
what the reasons behind that were.
There was definitely, with the
Spanish, all of this influx
of new ingredients
that came to Italy.
And Italy really, really
embraced every single one.
What's interesting is some of --
because of the Turkish influence.
And the Turks were in charge
of a lot of trade at the time.
A lot of the products that were
new into Italy, got Turkish names.
So like, you know, products
that are made with corn a lot
of times get called [foreign
word], or Turkish grain.
And it has nothing
to do with Turkey,
other than that the
Turks were the middlemen.
Turkish coffee, you know, they
didn't get the coffee from Turkey,
but they were bringing it around.
So it got labeled as Turkish.
And so we see these words
a lot of times in Italy.
And it, you know, up
until very recently,
if someone in a very small
community came from another place.
A lot of French people called them a
Turk, because they came from a part.
So you can't always use
etymology in food history.
Sometimes it leads you
to something different.
It's just a little provincial thing.
We have corn, tomatoes, potatoes,
vanilla, avocados, peppers.
All kinds of things
coming from the New World.
And here's an example of, you
know, some different dishes.
This one is a [foreign
word] dish on the left.
They have a saying that if
it has peppers, and tomatoes,
and onions, it's [foreign word].
But, as we can see, a lot of
those ingredients, you know,
two of those ingredients, at
least, came from the New World.
And many people don't realize
what Italian food would be
without tomato sauce,
prior to the 15th century.
But, Domenica and I
actually have a colleague,
who wrote a book called
Beyond the Red Sauce.
His name is Chef Matt Finarelli.
And it's all recipes
without tomato sauce,
that were done prior
to the 15th century.
So you can find that if
you're very interested.
Another thing that we have to think
about in Italian food
is the idea of realism.
And the idea of showing
food like it is.
And this kind of more
modern approach
in the way that we eat today.
And the way that we eat today,
even if you go to a restaurant
and you look at a menu, it
will tell you the ingredients.
It will say such-and-such salad.
Then it will say
tomato/cucumber/onion,
and we list the ingredients.
That would not have
happened in the Renaissance.
In the Renaissance, they would want
50 million different ingredients
in there.
You know, wrapped in a crust,
which has an animal in it.
Which is stuffed with
something else.
And really, you had to like guess.
The food was like magic, and
a work of art, and a surprise,
and these kind of things.
So --
>> Domenica Marchetti:
Okay, but I have --
so, you're talking about
the Renaissance in Florence.
>> Amy Riolo: Sure.
>> Domenica Marchetti:
And all of that?
So what about the cucina povera,
and when did that come about?
I mean, was that always
there as well?
You know, you think of the
fagioli and just varied,
I think of Florentine cuisine
today as very minimalist, almost.
So when would that have come about?
>> Amy Riolo: We're going to get to
that in this slide in a little bit.
>> Domenica Marchetti: Okay.
>> Amy Riolo: It was always there.
But it came about more as a force,
a couple hundred years later.
So we're going to get to that.
But a similarity with the
art, which we may be seeing
at the National Gallery,
if people go to that talk.
Is something about Caravaggio
and Titian using the
realism in their work.
And showing things, portraying
as they are, more than creating
like things that are
kind of a fantasy world.
We're also going to
see that with the food.
And then we have these,
some of the influences
that to start coming
into the United States.
And we look at the different
influences on Italian architecture.
And things that our
Presidents were looking at.
And, as Domenica mentioned
earlier, definitely the food
and the wine of Jefferson.
And there are even these clips
that you can find, of the influence
that Jefferson was
under, of the Italians.
>> Domenica Marchetti: And he
had a winemaker who was Italian.
>> Amy Riolo: Right, Mazzei.
>> Domenica Marchetti:
[Inaudible] yes.
>> Amy Riolo: Exactly.
So he brought Mazzei over, and he
hands this little letter to him.
It says, I thank you for obliging --
the obliging act of
your culture of wine.
And I'm happy to hear
that your plantation
of them is in so prosperous a way.
So also, he brought over
people to teach Italian,
and to start an Italian
studies program.
So definitely a big
proponent of Italian culture.
He also smuggled rice into
the United States [laughter],
from the risotto.
So even though it has nothing
to do nowadays with risotto
and what grows in the south.
But you can see the
similarities from them,
just because he got it
and he brought it in.
So we have also our rice industry
to thank Jefferson
and the Italians for.
And here we are, Library
of Congress.
Go around, you know, some
of the different buildings.
And you can see just how beautiful a
lot of the Italian architecture is.
And here's when we start
to get more into the topic
about the cucina povera, and that
whole thing, and how it started.
So 1892 is when we really see the
mass immigration into the Americas.
And as Italians, as, you know,
people who are studying Italy.
Anybody who cares about
Italy at all,
if you look at this time period,
that's all you're going to see.
But there's a lot else
going on in Italy too.
So we're going to present a
little bit of both of that today.
So we see the, you know,
the immigration coming,
and people leaving, and
people having to leave.
And that, of course, changes a lot
about what food is
known as, in the world.
Here in America, if you study any
of the textbooks from, you know,
what they were teaching in the
tenements and things like that.
They would actually
send social workers
to the Italian neighborhoods
in New York.
And they would have them
come with their clipboards.
And, you know, they would
like analyze the families.
And they say, oh, you
know, you came from Italy
and you've got these kids.
And, you know, you're
just feeding them starch,
and there's no protein,
and vegetables.
That's not good, they
need meat and potatoes.
They're not going to live.
This is America, this is
what we do, we're advanced.
There was a lot of propaganda to
get people to eat meat and potatoes.
So, in addition to poverty,
being new immigrants, you know,
poor conditions, what
they were living in,
and food not being available.
They were also being told, this
is the way you have to eat.
So, you know, if anybody every
criticizes what happened to the,
you know, Italian-American food.
There's a really strong reason
to it, and in a certain way,
I think it's amazing that
so many food trends stayed,
despite everything that
people went through.
>> Domenica Marchetti: Right.
>> Amy Riolo: Now, again,
at the same time, you know,
not too much before, in Italy.
As we're talking about
despair, and people talk
about why people had to flee.
There was also a lot of
very great things going on,
considering opera to be one of them.
And Puccini was born
in 1858, in Lucca.
So Lucca is in Tuscany.
And what he ate would
have been known, he was --
would have been known as Lucchese,
or the specific food from his town.
So here we see some more
examples of Tuscan food.
And then, because it
was a feudal town,
and it was known for its wealth.
Later on, when it started
going through economic decline,
this is really when this term,
the cucina povera got coined,
and people started talking about it.
Because it was happening at the
same time as the mass immigration,
then it got brought here.
And then anything that
came, you know,
with these poor people, was poor.
And a lot of times what
was Italian was poor,
because it was coming with people.
But when it went around, you
know, through the opera starts
and through the other things, then
it had a different connotation.
And also, it's important
to note some very simple
ingredients, like beans, like wheat.
Fava beans, for example,
world's oldest agricultural crop.
Cheap as could be,
plentiful, and easy to find.
But they were, you know,
very expensive at the time.
They were a currency.
Lentils were a currency, they
were worth their weight in gold.
So things change at different times.
And I like to be very careful
about what I call poor and rich,
because it's all in the matter
of the way you look at it.
Plus, if it's good for you,
then it has a wealth, I
think, all of its own.
So here are some of the
examples of the cucina povera,
that Domenica was talking about.
We have the polenta and we
have the panzanella salad.
We have the pancotto.
So the first two are
recipes made out of bread.
So the pancotto on the bottom is
a soup made out of cooked bread.
It's just leftover
bread made into a soup.
You know, obviously very
cheap, inexpensive to make.
But, when done well, there are
few things that taste as great.
And nowadays, a homemade, authentic,
honest stock is probably one
of the biggest luxuries, I
think, you know, in humankind.
Then we have the panzanella
salad, which leftover bread.
People are taking advantage
of the good bread
to turn it into the salad.
And polenta, so polenta
comes from cornmeal.
Corn, of course, was
brought back with Columbus,
often called [foreign word].
And made into this
dish called polenta.
This is our Italian
version of grits.
But people didn't like it.
It didn't catch on very quickly.
People were suspicious of
it, it looked like food
that you would feed to the animals.
And it really didn't have,
you know, much repertoire.
But it caught on with the
Jewish community in the North,
and they started eating it.
And then it, little by little, it
became a little bit more widespread.
It spread to the south.
And then in the south, a lot
of the farmers started
eating it before they went
out into the fields in the morning.
So it would be a base.
They would eat it with meat,
and they were these very big,
untraditional, not what we
think of as Italian breakfasts.
Because they had to work the
-- they had to work the land.
And then in 1889, the
first pizzeria was born.
So we all know, of
course, we don't have
to tell anybody how
popular pizza is.
But it's very important
that it has -- the pizzeria.
And it's important that you look
at the Queen Margherita, and why,
what she has to do with the pizza.
Does anybody know this story?
Okay. Okay, so some of you.
So, you know, it was
a very humble food.
It was a street food.
It wasn't something that
the Queen would order.
But, how they used to
sell the pizza was,
if anybody's ever been
to Istanbul or Cairo.
And you see the people walk around
with those big aluminum tanks
that are, they're getting water or
juice or something from these things
that are strapped onto them.
Well, they used to strap
ovens onto themselves, and go,
they were like human vendors.
And they would heat the pizza
up and sell it on the street.
It was very, very poor,
you know, food.
And the Queen had a craving for one,
so she ordered one up to the castle.
They made the tri-colored one for
her, in honor of the Italian flag.
And this is how we got
the Margherita pizza.
So you can still go to
visit this Pizzeria Brandi,
if you go to Naples.
And then also Verdi.
So it's important to
think about opera,
once again, at this time period.
Because opera was so important,
and I do whole lectures
on the influence of opera on food.
But Verdi was very closely
associated with the Risorgimento.
So his work was very political.
And a lot of his writings
and his music had understated
political, hidden messages.
And these are important,
because at the same time,
all of this unification
was going on in Italy.
So there was a need for
unification of food.
They were actually looking for food
that would bring the
country together.
Because, at the time, the
foods were all very regional
and very different.
And that's how we still like
to kind of look at it today.
But they were looking, as
they were looking for a hero.
A singer or a sports figure,
they also wanted food.
And one of the things that
Verdi's legacy left was,
he created some songs, and
popularized some songs,
Italian songs around the world.
That, you know, are,
people just hear the tune
and they start humming them.
And that's one of the many things
that he gave us, in
terms of culture.
So if you look at Milan in that
time, where the alla Scalla is,
and the teatro, and
very fine dining.
And wonderful things are happening
there today, in terms of gastronomy.
We can also, you know,
way back in his time,
this wasn't that much
going on at that time.
So they had a lot of local products.
They had the wonderful
dairy that they had,
they had the farms
and things like that.
Risotto, minestre, and
freshwater fish, this was the basis
of what was going on
in Milan, at the time.
And Verdi also has a
risotto named after him.
So you can look this up
online, if you're a Verdi fan,
and make this risotto when
you listen to the opera.
But here are the regions, as
they are today, as I mentioned.
So, you know, they weren't
exactly the same at that time.
But you can see kind of the
differences, and how they evolved,
and how they developed, and
what's unique to one another.
Even within the regions, there are
still differences between the town.
You know, a town one hour
away, two hours away,
will have a different dialect,
different food, different terrain.
And when you go, you get to see it.
And this, as Domenica mentioned,
really helped to shape the
different things of the food.
So one region that we
know of very, very well,
for food in the world today, is
the region of Emilia-Romagna.
And especially the town of Parma.
So Parmigiano-Reggiano is the
most famous cheese from there,
and the most famous cheese
known around the world.
It's said that Benjamin Franklin
even tried to get the recipe.
And it has an eight-century history.
Very meticulous process of what
they have to do to make it.
And it's all governed by
the government and all
of these types of consortiums.
So you know you were getting an
authentic product when you go there.
For those of you who like the
Prosciutto di Parma, the --
sorry for the small p on the Parma.
For those of you who like it, you
will find that one of the things
that makes it unique, is that the
pigs are fed the leftover whey
from making the Parmigiano-Reggiano.
That's one of the reasons
why it gets so much flavor,
in addition to the different
breeds and the different things.
These types of food
traditions are one of the things
that helps the Italian economy.
That helps the gastronomy
around the world,
and it helps what makes the
Made in Italy brand strong.
So nowadays, one of the things
that we're doing is really trying
to promote geographic indicators.
A lot of times, people will come
and will have events here in D.C.
from Switzerland, and from
U.N. and different places.
If we can protect, for
example, the Idaho potato,
and the Prosciutto di
Parma, and things like this,
different economies do better.
You know, there's a lot
more increased trade.
People know what they're buying
and they get authentic products.
So it's a thing of the
future, that to look at.
But getting back to the
unification of Italy.
So Garibaldi, who is
probably, you know,
considered to be the father
of the [foreign word].
And very important General
in the Italian Army,
and in causing the
unification of Italy.
He first ate Spaghetti
al Pomodoro in Calabria,
at this place that
you see over there.
Melito di Porto Salvo.
And he said to the
soldiers, "I swear to you,
this will be the dish
that unifies Italy."
So for those of us who,
like, when we see the dish,
and we're like oh, no,
it's stereotypical.
It's not. Garibaldi endorsed it.
That's all we need.
We can have it for 5,000 more years.
And then, of course, we start
to see the mass-produced pasta.
And, you know, why was there such
a need for mass-produced pasta?
Well, this is when people
really started leaving Italy.
So they're leaving Italy.
They can't bring with them
their pasta making tools, maybe.
They don't have maybe the new
ingredients to make pasta.
They're going to need pasta.
And one of the things
that [inaudible] the
way of packaged pasta.
And pasta chuta, as we call
it, dried pasta in the world,
is this mass immigration.
So then we have this invention
of Italian-American cuisine.
So nowadays, what people were
eating, maybe on a Sunday, in Italy,
as a, you know, luxury food.
We're eating more and more
commonly as a daily food in America,
because meat is cheap here.
Meat still is cheaper than herbs.
And then a lot of vegetables,
and very easy to get.
You know, dandelion greens, which
we used to eat by the bushel-full
when I was a kid, are expensive.
Meat, on the other hand, is cheap.
And so there's a sort of, there's a,
you know, health component to that.
Because you have, the name
for dandelion, in Latin,
is official disease remedy.
And they're expensive.
So, but --
>> Domenica Marchetti:
But also portions.
>> Amy Riolo: Yes.
>> Domenica Marchetti: I mean,
portions are a big issue, I think.
And that's a problem here.
Because everybody in
the U.S. seems to think
that Italians eat all the time,
you know, gargantuan portions.
And, of course, if
you go over there,
that's not the way it is at all.
>> Amy Riolo: Right.
>> Domenica Marchetti: You know,
look at that plate of spaghetti.
That's a very American
way of serving.
[ Laughter ]
No offense.
>> Amy Riolo: And then, in 1891,
there's a book that we actually,
Lucia provided for us
out there, you can see.
La Scienza en cucina e
l'arte di mangiar bene.
This was a very important
book, written by Artusi,
that all the Italian chefs study.
And anybody who's interested in
Italian food should look at it.
Because it talks about
verismo in the kitchen.
So again, this ideal of
realism, like we were talking
about with Titian and
Caravaggio comes in.
And this was written
for the middle classes.
So, unlike Apicius, who was
writing for, you know, the emperors,
and he was a philosopher.
And unlike, later on,
people who were writing
for the cooks of the kings.
He was actually writing
for the middle classes.
>> Domenica Macchetti: And,
one thing about Artusi is
that he was from, I
think, Emilia-Romagna,
but lived for years in Florence.
So I guess the majority
of the recipes
in his book were from that region.
But he did gather recipes
from around the peninsula.
And so that was kind
of considered maybe one
of the first regional cookbooks.
And it helped to unify, you know,
what we know of as Italian cuisine.
>> Amy Riolo: That's
a really good point.
That's a very good point.
Because, prior to that, the
books would have been, you know,
from wherever they were written.
Or from wherever the
author was written.
In the 19th century, so with the
continuing changes that we see,
are a lot more lighter,
more fresh ingredients.
Again, we're getting away
from those heavily spiced,
really intricate recipes
of the Renaissance.
Then comes along Puccini.
And now we're seeing verismo in
this idea of realism in the opera.
And Puccini talking about
very middle-class scenes.
And very everyday things
that you can see.
And not trying to be so elevated.
This, again, is something
that transformed
and it shows in the kitchen.
And then also, Puccini,
because of his success,
and because of the different
global things that he talked about.
He had things set in Asia.
He had things set in Paris.
So against the backdrop
of this mass immigration,
and people aren't afforded to live.
You also have people who are
really upholding the high end
of Italian culture.
And telling people, okay, this
is really what we're capable of,
in addition to some of the
problems that are going on.
Then we have the futurist
movement in food.
And I know you're going to be
hearing a talk on that very soon,
so I won't go in too much.
But this is really fun.
I can't endorse it too much, because
the first one, no more pasta.
Which, to me, life
wouldn't be worth living.
But they did have some
kind of cool ideas.
One of them was that
the meals had to be
in perfect harmony with one another.
They had these wonderful
table settings.
They had all of these
kind of sculpted foods.
Some of the foods,
you didn't even eat.
They were just placed on the table
for your eyes, and to attract you,
and as, you know, eye candy.
>> Domenica Marchetti: This is
modernist cuisine, you know.
>> Amy Riolo: Yes, yes.
But you literally didn't eat them.
They disallowed political
speech at the table,
which I think is a great idea.
They also forbid music and
poetry, which is weird.
Because a lot of the more
elaborate things up until that day,
they used to would
actually have people come
and recite poetry before you ate.
Or sing a song or something
like that.
And then they, probably
the most bizarre thing,
was that they would have these
little simulators of airplanes,
like they have at the
Air and Space Museum.
They'd have people go
in there and sit to eat.
And then they would have,
they would stimulate movements
that were supposed to
make people more hungry.
And open up their appetite.
So, but I'll leave that for the
person who's special in that.
Then, as we move forward, we
look, we start to develop, by now,
in Italy, a really
strong sense of style.
That's respected all over the world.
So despite problems and
despite immigration and things
that might have been immigration
-- attributed to it in the past.
By now, we're very respected all
around the world, in terms of Made
in Italy and Italian style.
And this is a quote
by Diego Della Valle.
Also, language and food, so many
of our American food products
now have Italian names.
Some of them are changed
a little bit,
but a lot of them are straight on.
You know, pizza, ravioli, pasta.
Bologna, of course, is
a whole different thing,
but that's [inaudible] Italian word.
Coffee, pepperoni.
Pepperoni, in Italian, is peppers.
So there is no like pork product
that we call pepperoni,
that does not --
>> Domenica Marchetti: Yeah.
>> Amy Riolo: -- It's not there.
But all of these words
are some of them.
And also, we see fashion,
and different American-style
icons turning to Italy.
Like Jackie O and different
actresses, for their fashion.
That really helped.
Food and fashion go hand-in-hand.
And whenever people like one,
they usually like the other.
So this really helped with the
food to be spread in the world.
And films, you know,
by Dino Di Laurentis
and Carlo Ponti, and Sophia Loren.
All of these wonderful actresses.
Also, American movies
that are going to Italy.
Now, by this time, Americans want
to have their movies shot in Italy.
So this, again, added to the appeal.
And, of course, music.
We had so much great music that
was coming out of this area.
And then American travel.
By now, Americans could
afford to travel.
And, you know, we had a
type of disposable income
that would let us go to Italy.
So once people went to Italy
and saw it for themselves,
that's how it became such a great
tourist destination that it is.
We saw huge changes in
the 1970s and the 1980s,
in terms of what people
thought Italian food was.
What you could get in restaurants.
What recipes were available.
All kinds of misconceptions.
You know, they started out with the
now, we're not just Italian anymore,
but we're Northern versus Southern.
And there was that whole thing.
>> Domenica Marchetti: Which
is still a simplification
of the way it actually is.
>> Amy Riolo: Yes, yeah.
And sometimes it's just
because you're on Twitter
and you only have a certain
amount of characters to use.
And you can't say --
[ Foreign Language ]
[ Laughter ]
You have to just say South.
>> Domenica Marchetti: But
it's changed since then.
I mean, you know, we
don't really see too much
of the Northern/Southern
anymore, right?
I think it's much more regional.
You know, there's an attempt
to really dig down deeper
into Italian cuisine here in the
U.S. And, I think, around the world.
>> Amy Riolo: And then,
of course, by the '90s,
a lot of Italian food is
associated with gourmet.
So now we have things that aren't
even Italian, using Italian names.
Putting Italian cities.
Putting Italian words, or, and, you
know, of course, with the olive oil.
We won't go there today,
but it's a big thing.
Because, by now, we've
got a gourmet reputation.
And so people start to do that,
and also take advantage of it.
And then, one of the wonderful
things that we're doing
and we see being done, is people
preserving the artisan pastas.
So, here we have --
>> Domenica Marchetti: So this is a
chitarra, from the Abruzzo region,
which is where my family is from.
And this is --
>> Can you go to show to the people?
>> Domenica Marchetti: Okay.
>> Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so --
>> Sorry.
>> Domenica Marchetti:
No, no, no, that's fine.
So I'll just kind of put
it on the chair here.
>> Thank you.
>> Domenica Marchetti: This
is actually a tourist one.
I have my mother's, but I
didn't want to bring it,
because it's kind of in bad shape.
But this is actually a
19th century invention.
It was apparently invented
by the [foreign word].
The artisans who made the -- what
do you call a [foreign word]?
>> Amy Riolo: Sieve.
>> Domenica Marchetti:
The sieves, yeah.
So when you made pasta, or
whatever, you sieved your flour,
because you wanted to get rid
of all the little bits,
and you save the rest.
But this was actually a way to sort
of make cutting your pasta
easier for housewives.
So you put your strip of pasta on
here and you'd roll this, you know,
this rolling pin along it.
And you'd cut the sheet
of pasta into strips.
So until very recently, Abruzzo was
really the only place you could get
something like spaghetti
a la chitarra.
But now, if you go down to Rose's
Luxury, you can get [inaudible].
Because it's become very popular.
And this is what is happening
with regional Italian cuisine.
That, you know, cooks,
cookbook authors,
chefs, are really digging down.
Because every region, I say --
I always say that Italy
is a small country.
But every region is vast and deep.
And, you know, I know
that every time I go back,
I come across recipes
that are new to me.
That are either very old or
very new, and there's just,
there's always something
to discover.
Which is pretty incredible,
when you think
about how many centuries people
have been traveling to Italy.
And have been mining its
food and its culinary scene.
So the fact that there are
still discoveries to be made,
I think, are pretty incredible.
>> Amy Riolo: I agree.
And as we talk about that, in
Italian food around the globe.
This is a map that's
from Yelp, in Singapore.
And you can see how many different
tiramisu restaurants there are.
Tiramisu is the number
one dessert in Singapore.
They love -- they're crazy about it.
And many places in the world.
In Morocco, I was seeing
it all over the place.
And also restaurants named for it,
but it is definitely the most
famous Italian dessert in the world.
>> Domenica Marchetti: So and I want
to say one thing about Singapore.
Because I met a chef from Singapore,
when I was in Italy
over this summer.
And he's actually Japanese, but
he has a restaurant in Singapore,
and it's an Italian restaurant.
And he just won a Michelin Star.
So that's, you know,
talk about global,
that's pretty incredible, yeah.
>> Amy Riolo: That's awesome.
That's awesome.
And do you want to
talk about your --
>> Domenica Marchetti: Oh yeah,
so you see those teeny-tiny
little bagels.
That's my daughter's hand, actually.
We were in Florence in
this, over the summer.
And they, our hotel at happy
hour, or whatever, cocktail hour,
will put out wine and some
little [foreign word],
little things to eat.
And one day, it was
these many bagels.
So here we are in the heart of
Florence, snacking on mini bagels.
And if you go to Italy, you know,
or the world of the
internet, and food blogging.
I know a lot of Italian
food bloggers.
And if you look at their sites,
you'll see recipes for muffins
and cheesecake, and,
you know pancakes.
And when I go to Italy, I don't
want to have bagels, you know.
[ Laughter ]
That's a personal preference.
But, of course, you
know, if you're Italian,
you might want to have
bagels, I guess.
I don't know.
So it's a shifting
landscape, I guess.
>> Amy Riolo: And also,
you have the,
you've seen the sushi
with the Italian flag.
And over on the right,
the pizza and kabobs.
So very common, especially in Rome.
I lived in Rome for a while.
And the places where they have the
pizza Italia or the hand cut pizza,
will also have a shawarma
stand over in the corner.
A lot of them are run by
people from the Middle East.
But they don't call them a
shawarma, they call them kabob,
which after the doner
kabob, for the Turkish name.
So and some people, you
know, have an opinion
about that and they don't like it.
They think that they're
ruining the pizzerias,
and they're ruining their culture.
But, if we look back to the history
of pizza, the word pizza comes
from [foreign word],
which is Turkish.
So I think it's fair.
And there's lots of
tiramisu in Turkey, so --
>> Domenica Marchetti:
Well, and of course,
if you go up to the Gran Sasso,
you can eat [foreign word]
kabobs out of [foreign word].
Which are made with mutton,
and they're really delicious.
So, you know, I'm sure that
those [foreign word] had their
origin elsewhere.
And they were a typical
food of the shepherds
who passed through the area.
And they're delicious.
So slow food, when I was
working on preserving Italy,
I spoke with a number
of food artisans.
And I profiled a few in the book.
But some of them work with the slow
food movement and an organization.
And one of the wonderful things
that they're doing is they are,
they have been working to preserve,
you know, specific varieties
of tomatoes, or artichokes,
or beans.
And they're not just
doing this in Italy,
they're doing this around the world.
So these traditions and these
foods are not lost to us.
>> Amy Riolo: You could also
join Slow Food D.C. We have a
local chapter.
They give something called the
snail of approval to local purveyors
and restaurants who use
local, sustainable ways.
So if you're here, it's
a great thing to do.
And then we'll end
with this great quote.
[ Foreign Language ]
So, the food that you
enjoy is best digested.
And thank you all.
We'd love to take questions,
if you have them.
>> Domenica Marchetti: Yeah.
[ Applause ]
Yes, ma'am.
>> Okay, I always have
multi-parted questions.
So for the first time this
weekend, I at [inaudible].
>> Domenica Marchetti: You ate what?
>> Reginetti.
>> Domenica Marchetti:
Oh, reginetti.
>> Yes, [inaudible]?
>> Domenica Marchetti: So
that's a great question.
And I don't know if
there's a specific answer.
There's all the varieties
of dried pasta.
And then all the varieties
of fresh pasta.
So where did you have
your reginetti?
>> In New York.
>> Domenica Marchetti: In New York.
So I wonder if it was a fresh pasta?
>> It was fresh.
>> Domenica Marchetti: It was fresh.
What does it -- what
did it look like?
>> Like a little kind
of squiggled ribbons,
kind of twisted, with
a scalloped edge.
And, you know, maybe a --
>> Domenica Marchetti: Yeah, I mean,
especially in the last
couple of decades.
The shapes have -- there have
just been more and more shapes
that come out, and
they're very whimsical.
And some are traditional,
but many these days are not
traditional anymore.
I mean, there's a shape
now that I see
in stores, called the calamarata.
And it looks like a calamari ring
and you serve it with
a seafood sauce.
But, you know, when I was
growing up, that didn't exist.
So I don't know if
there's an answer.
I would say hundreds.
I mean, yeah, honestly.
>> Amy Riolo: But also,
sometimes people take pastas
that are traditionally made fresh.
And they make them into a
dry pasta, or vice versa.
>> Domenica Marchetti: Right.
>> Amy Riolo: One that's
normally dry, then they'll start,
in a restaurant, they'll say,
oh, we want to do that fresh.
But in Italy, there
might not be a tradition
of making that pasta fresh.
That happens too.
>> Domenica Marchetti: Yeah.
>> And the second part
of my question is,
exactly what does antipasto mean?
And why is it called -- why is
mortadella called mortadella?
>> Domenica Marchetti:
So antipasto is --
anti is before, pasta,
before the meal.
So it's your appetizer, essentially.
And mortadella is called
mortadella because, I don't know.
Do you?
[ Laughter ]
Does anybody know?
I'd love to know that.
That's a good one.
I'll --
>> We'll research it.
>> Domenica Marchetti: Yeah.
>> [Inaudible] Something like that.
But it's delicious.
>> Domenica Marchetti:
Yeah, I don't know.
That's a great question.
>> First of all, I want
to thank you, both of you,
for these illuminating speeches.
Are wonderful to hear
from you all about Italy.
[Inaudible] so we don't
know never enough, you know.
So I do have a question.
So when I grew up in the
restaurants, my mother was a chef,
my grandmother was a chef.
I'm not a chef, but I eat
it a lot, and we are --
>> Domenica Marchetti:
Where, in Italy?
>> Liguria.
>> Domenica Marchetti: Oh, the best.
Wonderful.
>> So when I moved here ten years
ago, and every day mostly that I go.
Like today, [inaudible] invite me
for lunch in an Italian restaurant.
And it's the most awful
thing [inaudible].
I see on the menu, pasta
with Alfredo sauce.
Where is this coming from?
Because we don't have that.
I never have in Italy,
have Alfredo sauce.
And here it's everywhere,
in the [inaudible].
So can you please help me to --
>> Domenica Marchetti: So
that's a great question.
I know it's not Italian.
>> No.
>> Domenica Marchetti:
And I'm surprised to hear
that places still serve it.
Because I had mentioned that I think
a lot of chefs are really trying
to do justice to Italian food.
Using local ingredients, but --
[ Inaudible Comment from Audience ]
So, do you know the story?
>> Amy Riolo: Yeah,
the popular story,
whether it's lore or real or not.
Was in the early part of
the 20th century, in Rome,
a lot of the actors and
actresses were going there.
And Mary Pickford, who is a
prominent silent film star, actress,
here in the United States.
Went to one of the Roman chefs
and asked for something like,
similar to like [foreign
word], but with cream.
And so they made that for her.
And apparently, his name was
Alfredo, and the recipe came
to be known as Alfredo sauce.
So even though it's not an Italian
recipe that people would eat
and enjoy at home, it came back
here because she was Mary Pickford.
So it got introduced
as an Italian recipe.
>> Right, okay.
Thank you so much.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Domenica Marchetti: Yeah.
>> -- You know, when
other people go.
>> Domenica Marchetti: There
are other dishes like that.
Yes.
>> Susan Finstead [phonetic].
It's such a pleasure to be
here and to learn about this.
Not to say anything
except something good.
Are there places that you
can recommend in Washington,
D.C., to get Italian food?
That isn't Italian style, but would
be something that would seem to you
to be what you would enjoy?
>> Domenica Marchetti: I
can tell you what I enjoy.
And it's not like going to a
restaurant in Italy, necessarily.
But, like I said, I do think
that chefs are really
trying to do justice.
Now, I haven't been
in a number of years.
But Obelisk is, you know, said to
be a good Italian restaurant here
in D.C. That's been
around for a long time.
I am a fan of Michael Schlow's
restaurant, Alta Strada.
Which, yeah, Alta Strada, which is
on K Street, and that's pretty new.
And he's opened a seafood
restaurant called Casolare.
So those are a couple.
Nick Stefanelli, in,
near Union Market,
has a restaurant called Masseria,
which is very high-end, but Italian.
And also high-end, are
the Fiola and Fiola Mare.
So are they, I mean, and
the Chef from Fiola is
from Le Marche, Fabio Trabocchi.
So, you know, you can get --
it's still not, to me, I mean,
the food at these places, I
think is really wonderful.
It's not like going to,
you know, an agriturismo
in the Maiella mountains.
Which is like what I
like to do when I'm --
[ Laughter ]
-- But, yeah.
I think there's -- do you have --
>> Amy Riolo: I also
recommend Al Tiramisu
on P Street, and Aperto on I Street.
>> Domenica Marchetti: Right,
and he's from Basilicata, right?
>> Amy Riolo: Yes.
>> Domenica Marchetti: So
he's from Italy as well.
Yeah.
>> Amy Riolo: You had a question.
>> You pointed out the regional
variations of food in Italy.
Well, of course, Italian-American
food is very varied too.
Especially like pizza.
Like, I swear by New Haven Pizza,
especially with the
white clam sauce.
But, versus that bread in Chicago.
>> Domenica Marchetti:
Deep-dish pizza.
Yeah, yeah.
>> And, of course, Detroit
style pizza and St. Louis pizza.
Of course, in St. Louis,
they fry the ravioli.
>> Yeah.
>> Domenica Marchetti: Yeah, so
there are regional differences
in Italian-American
cuisine, for sure.
Yeah.
>> Are any of them popular in Italy?
>> Domenica Marchetti:
Not that I know of.
[ Laughter and Multiple Speakers ]
I don't think they're popular.
There is some -- I
did see somewhere,
that there is an Italian-American
restaurant that has --
>> Amy Riolo: In Rome
>> Domenica Marchetti: In Rome?
I thought it was Milano.
Really?
>> Amy Riolo: Maybe both.
Maybe both.
>> Domenica Marchetti: So --
>> Amy Riolo: I've
seen the Rome one.
>> Domenica Marchetti: So
the food came back here
and now it's gone back there.
I'd be curious to try it.
I, you know, maybe, I don't know.
Yeah. Yes.
>> I have a question.
When I lived in Italy, or when I
first, you know, lived in Italy.
I was told a lot of
things, like first of all,
you do not order cappuccino
after noon.
>> Domenica Marchetti:
That's right, that's right.
>> Never, ever, and that kind
of tags you as an American.
Or, you know, a non-Italian.
>> Yeah.
>> And the second thing was that
you never, ever put grated cheese
on seafood pasta or mushroom pasta.
>> Domenica Marchetti:
Mushroom, yes.
>> But, is that a practice, is
there some kind of rule about this?
>> Domenica Marchetti: Yes,
and best not to question it.
[ Laughter ]
You know, cappuccino
is a breakfast drink.
If you have it in the afternoon,
it'll sit in your stomach
like a stone.
You know, that's what
I think the Italian --
but we all have our own habits.
I mean, here, we drink,
you know, coffee, or the --
[ Foreign Language ]
-- I don't know how big,
Starbucks, you know.
And then I think there are rare
exceptions with the seafood.
And I thought of one the other
day, and now it escapes me.
But, in general, seafood
doesn't call for cheese.
They just clash of flavors.
And does anybody have a more
specific answer to that?
>> Amy Riolo: Yeah, well not
more to that, but just to add on.
There are so many more.
And that's one of the
things that, when people try
to learn about Italian food.
Is that they might learn how to make
a recipe, or they might learn how
to make two or three things.
But even pairing them
together, when to serve them,
or what goes together,
is so difficult.
So one of my main objectives for the
series I'm going to teach next year.
For example, in a course, you would
never have soup and then pasta.
It's soup or pasta,
as a first course.
And but there, sometimes I find
American chefs doing Italian food,
and they'll have like
a prefixed menu.
It's like soup, and then
pasta, and then, you know,
and it's really, it's
strange to see it.
It's -- and I once described
it to one of my editors as,
you putting these together in a
picture, is like putting a corndog
on a silver platter on
an American cookbook.
Like, nobody would do it.
So there are a lot of things.
It takes time.
And when you're there,
you learn them.
And you could get little
by little, in cookbooks.
But I don't think anybody
has ever done one thing
that has like all the rules.
You know, that would be fun.
>> Domenica Marchetti: That would be
fun, and a very complicated process.
>> Yeah, [inaudible].
>> Amy Riolo: Very controversial.
Any other questions.
Well, we thank you all for --
>> Domenica Marchetti: Yeah, thank
you so much for coming, everybody.
[ Applause ]
>> Lucia Wolf: Thank
you all for coming.
I am going to introduce Renato
Miracco, the cultural attach
of the Italian embassy
in Washington,
D.C. Because he will give us some
conclusions about this event.
>> Renato Miracco: Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, Lucia, I
really, really thank you.
As you know, this is the first day
of the Italian Cuisine
in the United States.
They decide just to have
during the Thanksgiving week.
But I say, are you getting crazy?
During the Thanksgiving week,
we cannot have just the Italian
Cuisine in United States.
So we decide just to anticipate.
And thank you to Domenica, thank
you to Amy, it was really amazing.
This is really the
big start of the week.
This will be just only the start.
Maybe next year will be, we have
much more time, just to think about,
just some news about cuisine.
We started, anyway, we started
with the Library of Congress.
And I'm really honored just
to be a partner of this one,
with the Library of Congress.
We started just idea to have just
the new idea of food, in September,
when we were part of a festival.
National festival book, with two
events related to Italian cuisine.
So, and we thought about why
we can give just a new images
of Italian cuisine.
Because the mix of
generation, the mix of culture.
The mix of people all
over the world.
And then we have to update
the idea of Italian cuisine.
In the meantime, we have to
preserve old Italian cuisine.
And this is another
project that I'm leading.
So preserving our heritage
is another thing
that the Italian Embassy at
UNESCO are doing this year, 2016.
And we'll do in '17 and '18.
What doesn't mean that just
to preserve our culture,
preserve our monuments.
Preserve, in the meantime,
our recipe, our smell.
Something that we can give
to the next generation.
So Eliza will be there.
Sign if you would like to,
and thank you for coming.
And thank you, really, Lucia, to
host another beautiful event here.
I thank you too, both of you.
[ Applause ]